democratic education is based on the
belief that children themselves know
best what is good for them the job of a
school is to provide a democratic
structure in which kids can discover
their interests and learn how to live in
a community that solves conflicts
together the ideal to grow up in absence
of fear and to become responsible and
Pathak and self determined citizens the
idea is not new in 1693 the philosopher
john locke wrote that things children
learn should never be a burden to them
some 200 years later the writer Leo
Tolstoy opened a school for peasant
children on his estate in Russia the
school evolved from ideas introduced by
teachers and pupils one of the
principles was that the students had the
right to not listen to the teacher the
first democratic school that still
exists is Summer Hill in Suffolk England
it was founded in 1921 by a s Neill who
believed that a school should be made
for the child rather than the other way
around class attendance is voluntary
some children may spend weeks in the
woods or do nothing all day while others
choose to learn maths or try out reading
class when they grow older many turn to
traditional subjects with full focus
when they realize that they need them
for college entrance exams
at weekly school meetings staff and
students gathered to solve conflicts
once a conflict is brought to the
meeting everybody in this school can
speak up mediate or come up with a
solution
after the conflict is discussed and
democratically processed harsh feelings
are often buried and staff and students
live peacefully the meetings are also
used to work on the school regulations
and anybody can make a proposal for a
change of the rules if one student
requests a change members discuss and
then decide by popular vote whether the
new idea will be implemented sometimes
the kids may vote for the abolishment of
all rules but after a few days of total
chaos students usually use the same
democratic process to re-implement order
almost as if they all naturally seek
structure in the 1960s young educators
from all over took inspiration from
Summerhill and opened so-called free
schools one was the Sudbury Valley
School which was founded in
Massachusetts United States Sudbury took
the ideals of a democratic education
even further once a year the school
meeting is used to relate teachers and
principals those that don't receive
majority vote will be replaced today
there are many independent Sudbury and
other democratic schools all over the
world spanning from Brazil to Israel to
Thailand using different structures they
all promote the idea that students and
teachers should have an equal say in
what to learn and how to work with each
other the goal is to give children a
deep sense of equality and justice
Albert Einstein famously said the only
thing that interferes with my learning
is my education what do you think would
a democratic education work for you
please share your thoughts in the
comments below
you